le fait de ne pas pouvoir avoir
d'orgasme ça s'appelle la norgation et
vous allez voir qu'il y a aussi tout un
tas de cas de figure qui s'approchent
plus ou moins de la d'orgasmie sans être
la même chose exactement
dans le Dictionnaire de l'Académie de
médecine on parle d'absence ou de retard
après une période d'excitation normale
de l'orgasme l'orgasme ça n'est pas un
trouble de la libido il y a du désir
c'est juste l'orgasme qui est absent ce
n'est pas la sexualité non plus et
l'absence d'attirance sexuelle ça n'est
pas la frigidité ça c'est un terme un
peu nul on va se l'avouer pour décrire
l'absence ou la diminution de plaisir
une anorgasmie ça nous empêche pas de
ressentir du plaisir si le problème est
neurologique c'est à dire si les nerfs
sont touchés soit par une maladie comme
le diabète ou la sclérose en plaques par
exemple ou s'ils ont été abîmés par un
accident ou par une opération
là ça peut être compliqué mais tout ça
ça reste rare parce que dans 95% des cas
la cause elle est psychologique et là on
peut faire quelque chose